J'avais huit ans ma mère est morte elle
adorait parcourir le monde et fouiller dans
le passé il visitait tout le temps
pas un jour tout a changé elle avait
trouvé quelque chose quelque chose qu'il voulait il
m'aurait tué aussi
le monde change rien ne peut supporter
face à cela,
nous sommes Londres
avant sa mort,
votre mère m'a dit qu'elle avait peur de
Valentine et que si quelque chose
devait lui arriver, c'était pour vous trouver que
vous pouviez l'arrêter,
elle pourrait être un problème si elle
ressemble à une mère  ce qui se passe quand
tu trouves doit être sûr que
je donnerai
il est là
[Musique]
et le grand jeu de survie c'est
échec et mat
chérie tu ne me laisserais pas la taire et
courir tu es sûr que tu veux faire ça je dois le
faire pour ma mère
toi  regardez-la et tout ce que vous voyez, ce sont les
bords déchiquetés, mais elle est quelque chose de tout à fait
différent, elle est belle et étrange
et très
[Musique]
vous